[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
welcome to another episode of the omen
eSports report here and the beautiful
gfinity arena what we're bringing you 50
minutes of all things eSports now
unfortunately my partner-in-crime lot
your vampire can't be with us tonight so
what I did I did what I do best I picked
up my phone I got one of the best in the
business to come and join us today so
please welcome Rachel Sarina let's just
get one thing straight you didn't just
come you once no no three calls to
whatsapp the text and even a DM on
Twitter was it I just picked on the
phone I had a job to do and I got it
done well thank you so much me and I
have some pretty big shoes to fill all
right we have so much coming up so let's
take a look at what we have in store
tonight is what we've got in store for
you on today's show we'll be returning
to the headshot challenge we learned the
story of new arena shooter split game
and there's plenty to look forward to in
the month ahead incredible stuff to
bring you today as you can see Rachel
your first show what you looking for too
much well it's so much but I think
there's one thing called the rocket
League challenge which got going here
and isn't T naughty isn't she like one
nil up from the first show and it was
empty mati so I mean kinda later Thanks
thanks for bringing that up again and
really good to have you here Rachel
thank you so much I'm gonna put it right
today don't worry about it roll the
tiles
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and this kick things off with
the biggest headlines that have been
making the news last month 60 seconds on
the clock please
here we go g2 eSports secured an EU
victory at the midseason Invitational
Rainbow six siege continues its amazing
rise in popularity Team Liquid take the
top prize of two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and the ESL pro knee
final vitality break North American
hearts as they secure the our LCS season
seven championship core boys optic
gaming is parent company bought by
immortals of gaming club valve and royal
gaming announced their own versions of
the popular auto gesture the last pro
series announced September event in
Moscow Ferrari are announced as the
latest team to join the Formula One
eSport series and riot release details
of 2019 worlds dates and locations whoa
there's always so much there's always so
much I mean it's only a month what's
your point so did we here last time I
pick I've got to save rocket League or
assess champions vitality the european
boys as it said just they're breaking
North American hearts well I was gonna
say what about you
I'm gonna say that it's Ferrari during
joining f1 because now we have all the
10 manufacturers on the grid for that
date in July which is so exciting yeah
absolutely huge news but one piece of
news that we couldn't possibly fit into
just 60 seconds with all the exciting
reveals that took place at e3 this month
so we put all of our favorite things
into a handy video for you so let's take
a look at what that's good a little bit
hot under the collar
[Music]
I have like many things I want to ask
your inference I haven't got your time
though because you have to go up there
so see you in a little bit right now
Mark's gone we can play the clip of the
real winner of III and it could only be
one thing Eric could this is what went
down when Hollywood a-lister Keanu
Reeves got heckled during the cyberpunk
2077 reveal this is so cool
the feeling of of being there of walking
the streets of the future is really
going to be breathtaking so here we are
we are taking your breathtaking rate to
everyone at home is breathtaking as well
what a fantastic moment it was to see
Keanu Reeves on that stage at e3 doing
what he does best but we're here at the
control center and it is time to talk
about all of the social media happenings
that have been happening around the
globe in the world of eSports so we're
going to start off with something very
very simple today we're gonna be
starting off with the omen by HP
sponsored team empire celebrating their
success at the Rainbow six Series Pro
League finals we can take a look at that
right here because you know the guys
obviously had a fantastic time they won
pro league season 9 and they actually
were kind enough to put together a
little message for us so let's take a
very quick look hate everyone wishing
the on an eSports report and thank you
guys all for the support for League 9
finals were an incredible experience and
the last game versus individual assist
was very close to losing but we managed
to secure and we save our sporting
finals and bring home the title so make
sure guys you tune in and support us in
fully tens finals in Japan
good luck huge congratulations to the
guys obviously pick it up their
championship the next thing that we do
want to look out is a little bit of
spicy business actually going down it
was pretty funny to be honest with you
between g2 and splice you can see the
first tweet here that kind of sparked
everything off its recently come to our
attention that you've been grinding team
fighter tactics please stop sincerely
management now splice being splice
feeling you know a little bit fruity
maybe on this
just replied with don't stop sincerely
please every other LEC team this wasn't
the end of it though it just continued
dear splice please don't hijack our
statements
sincerely PR team as you can see here
please don't hijack our team's middle
lane as it gets a little bit more spicy
your mid laner has nothing to worry
about and then splice saying yeah you're
right it seemed pretty easy for him and
you'll see why in just a second because
well you can see it for yourself
you know splices mid laner having a
pretty good time at things but then you
know gee to fight back once more this is
what we call strategic intake and then
got to put the int on to international
success somehow I suppose then the
hammer blow comes in from g2 not you
guys know a lot about success and splice
had absolutely nothing to say in
response to that jeff goldblum pretty
much saying exactly what splice were
thinking so the next thing that we're
gonna be seeing is from the man the myth
the legend there is a Tyler t1 and he
Rashmi received a surprise package in
the post from eSports power house SK
Telecom t1 but what was inside well
let's find out this note says Tyler it's
celebration of our recent lck spring
split victory t1 would like to present
you this gift
t1 recognises t1 wait
notice how much taller I am than him as
well
hey goddamn no take I'll BRB honestly
some of the noises that tality will
makes just there are no words to
describe them be ever see he was pretty
hyped about that situation the next
thing that I've been keeping my eye on
is the price one for the international
in 2019 so I've got to say that I've
created this I haven't this wonderful
graph here it's a compendium watch to
show you why it is it's so exciting
right now we're on day 48 this is a
comparison of day 48 for the prize pool
total every year since 2015 and as you
can see right now 2019 is looking like a
bumper year for doughnut eSports the
International obviously one of the
biggest events of the year and that's
gonna look absolutely superb time for a
little bit of an omen by HP update now
to give you guys a little bit of an
insight on what's been going on in the
world appointment the finals of the omen
challenger UK League of Legends
tournament in partnership with Curry's
PC world took place this weekend live on
Twitch we saw an epic final showdown we
send claiming the title and winning
themselves a novelist gaming desktop
thank you to everyone who entered and
took part and a big shout-out to
runners-up my terrible name and get
barrows obviously a huge congratulations
to our champions there and everyone that
was involved but it's time to keep the
show moving so Rachel so via to you
thank you very much mark yeah there is
still loads to come in the show
including and that rocket League
challenge between me and Mark which I
cannot so wait for and you'll all be
wanting to pay particularly close eye on
that well why you ask well it's because
it's your chance to win a load of prizes
and they are pretty good all you have to
do is correctly predict whether team
mark or team Lottie
that's my team will win the rocket
League challenge details on how to enter
on the screen right now do join us for
that okay right it's the part of the
show that I cannot wait for it's time to
introduce
guess here they are all lovely and
waiting on the sofa guys yeah we're all
kind of waiting and great-aunts by the
way yeah it's very busy for us
particularly World of Warcraft right now
there's been a big patch released just
actually today in European Europe so
eight-point-two came out and there's a
big red race coming up in about three
weeks that were all kind of hands on
deck we're now preparing for we're so
lucky to have you here then if that's
all kind of happening it's so so true
obviously we're going to start off with
you too if that's okay with you I
believe that we've got a little packet
we have we're not trying to embarrass
you we just you don't know much about us
go and jari then take a closer look at
this
[Music]
I mean with two very different distinct
noise is therefore the way you use the
hashtag method way and that's kind of
your way I love seeing that
yeah those clips are definitely more the
exciting ones I guess you could say yeah
but see we want to talk a little bit
about method tell us a little bit about
the story how it came about and you know
your involvement yourself
so I started method when I was in
secondary school this is back in 2005 it
was all the work I've killed back then
and we fast-forward to today it's 75
players over nine different teams
content creation is like our absolute
core that's really what we focus on and
we're actually one of the most viewed
teams on twitch right now puts teams out
there but not just that we're also very
interested in exploring the angle of
doing like our own events something
we've been doing actively with the
vegetable first events the last two we
did and some stuff we done in the past
so that's definitely something we're
gonna be exploring a lot more in the
future you started like high school yeah
is that something you wanted to start I
was 16 when I got into it when I first
created the guild I want to say back
then I was playing a lot of strategy
games and I moved into dota and so I
actually thought well the Warcraft was
gonna be like a bigger improved version
of of dota like that at the same time
was the first ever my RPG I ever played
and so I was instantly hooked like I
instantly fell in love with the game and
as I went through the game and you know
progress more and more I realized that
you know I should want to achieve
everything I can in this game so the
first goal for our supposed to try and
be the best girl in the server and
that's what I remember whispering like
everyone on the server back then like
you'll join my guild we're gonna be the
best just took off from then we started
you know competing on the world stage
getting a lot of world first kills and
picking up a lot of traction that way
like even back then fort which was a
thing some of our youtube videos were
backing up like millions of views and
stuff so that's kind of how we released
started picking up taking themselves who
didn't join you
one other thing is obviously you know
it's not just World of Warcraft you have
kind of explored some other eSports well
another stumpy at the end there had the
opportunity some of your rocket League
players how did you find that experience
yeah the rocket League in particular you
mentioned has been great like and she
sees him for the chief in daily series
so actually right right here where we're
recording this show the method welcome
team actually managed to pick up the
trophy so that was that was a very proud
moment for sure that was awesome but no
we're definitely interested in exploring
you know pop the eSports titles for sure
our base is always gonna be able to work
after that's kind of where we came from
and we still are trying to push that
game as much as you can because you know
that's we love we love it basically
right so but focusing like the MMORPGs
or RPG kind of like sectors a gaming is
really is really a big focus for us
going forward so we moved into path of
Exile recently we're very excited for
things like dabble of for obviously all
the work I've classic coming out it's
just a really exciting time for us in
general so we'll be doing a lot of stuff
there and Jeri like you're sitting there
as well with your method t-shirt on a
lit just when did your involvement start
with method than your coming journey I
guess to come on pop yeah I guess I
guess I happened say like three and a
half years ago so when I met ASCO at
Dreamhack and he was telling me about
all of the plans that he had to grow
method and how he created the guild and
he wanted to bring it out from being
just a guild into an organisation and he
was talking to me about inviting
streamers to come play under the method
banner and I was like hey stories began
do you guys sitting there going pick me
now as well can we join the Warcraft you
were talking about low security let's
talk about high skilled things I wanted
to ask you sorry about that the race to
first because this is something you guys
have been heavily involved with and
you've had a lot of success with that
method
yeah the the race - well first is like
this unit like really unique community
driven event where the top teams in the
World of Warcraft compete to kill an end
boss at the highest difficulty first in
the world
as both the girlfriend of a Raider and
somebody who has commented and watched
these events happen it is quite an
intense these writers are playing like
anything like 1415 hours the day just
you know hacking away at the same boss
trying to kill with healthy food nicely
break something that you too could ever
do wait for like 16 hours normal day let
alone like playing like that and see
like just tell us how successful method
have become because it's usually like
method versus method in other elements
of work afters like the player presses
player element and there's also
something called the MDI the mythic
dungeon Invitational where basically
five players race against another five
players to go through a dungeon as fast
as possible
Blizzard have really started push that
in terms of the eSports program it's
very it's a very popular kind of concept
and yeah method has a North American
team and a European team on both the PP
side of the game and also the MDI side
of the game so most recently the MDI
finals in Australia had method na versus
honestly how easy was that to what it
was actually was a shock is all
Photoshop is all because method II you
had at she's been completely under feet
up until this point like they'd face
method the name many times and like the
smaller cops and they'd be in them every
single time they were undefeated record
wise they're 12 nil like and then they
go into the grand finals on the you know
the most important major coppers comp so
far and method there and they actually
managed to take them out I mean
everybody is gonna have a little
disappointing run they might as well
lose to your own team right
oh never mind it's good I think they're
still definitely an aspect of rivalry
between the teams obviously they want
their particular group of people that
they play with all the time to win right
so even if it is a method method finals
they still want to win it's very
compared to misspent it's kind of like
this across all these sports like North
America versus Europe is a very
competitive element oh yeah it's
extremely competitive yeah you so it's
it was it's fun but you know off the off
the game they're all really good friends
we all hang together at like events the
salsa well you did mention one thing
there you said interesting concepts and
the reason that I bring that up I know
it's a little bit more tenuous link
there there was an interesting quote
that came from blizzard recently and it
looks like we might be seeing some new
games in genres coming out from the
scene so we had some thoughts about what
we might see and we've you know in a
very funny way call it the blizzard
forecast good so let's open it up let's
open up the floor I mean what are we
thinking blizzards game titles jewelry
sitting out the back earlier yes
chatting about you yeah one of my one of
my friends he mentions over a year when
Blizzcon comes around
oh gosh darling you know they didn't
announce like Blizzard all-stars racing
but realistically I think that we'd be
more likely to expect an or chess I mean
that is the popular thing I'm just very
excited for Warcraft 3 V 4 that's where
I spent all my time basically was
Warcraft 3 so for that game to come out
again I think it's one of the best
strategy games ever made some I'm really
excited for it yeah we had some ideas
kind of like basically lets the stumpy
would enjoy there it is just arts world
Walker I'm actually really good at like
I'm gonna dance house revolution I'm
gonna say I'm really good at dance offs
I've got to exciting every now and then
I might bump my head on like like you
can't say that not just go up and show
we would make you do that one pretty
stressful the insurance is that one that
you at this game that you really enjoy
to be honest I would actually play like
lizard like racing all-stars I love a
racing game so yeah yeah you guys on a
viral like tweeting out or something
it all starts very soon it might
actually I would take a cut from that be
that the faces of it yeah I think I
probably would go with the dancing on as
well be fine we can have a dark wood you
have I can't get the dancing idea I want
to know what the best bit is I want an
eSports program for it as well I was
just dance eSports and it to be the most
competitive thing in the world I was a
lot of what I'm not gonna be a pro on
that I'll be the person learning anyway
we wanted to bring out the competitive
edge between two of our guests here
let's go and GRE so we asked them
earlier to face off in our head shot to
challenge the you can claim victory yes
ago a map it was pretty cool but got
away for this not really compare them
guy but alright this is the head shot
challenge it is go taking on jari they
have 60 seconds on the clock to get as
many head shots as possible but whilst
are doing that it's not that easy
because I'm me asking them some very
tricky questions right here it's going
you ready to take on Joey I am ready
it's a little bit weird
no feels good easy is that right
whenever you're ready
I think the clock has started so who is
the more entertaining streamer Joey who
has the worst morning breath Jerry go
Jerry we do that equally in turn nice
it's good question actually I settled
for our first I guess that probably
means I approached her first in real
life or online
I'm your life about 30 seconds who is
better at sea
let's go I'm hoping Scott no hi Ashley
oh okay she really good I'm not gonna
tell the school's just yet you'll have
to wait and see Jerry is up next
okay Joey is in the hot seat so right
now scones just been they gave some
pretty interesting answers as well you
might have to have a chat afterwards all
right yeah I'm not gonna tell you what T
got okay are you feeling confident no no
no I'm surprised that I just already
shot two to be honest all the time he's
already started yeah who is amazing
singing streamer me the worst morning
breath Scott who does the washing-up me
who asked the first date
Scott was it a liner was it in person
person oh who is better
çf go Scott okay 30 seconds left who is
the better cook me the reverse with my
terrible get ready me who owns the most
method merch Scott who watches the most
eSports face I got who makes the bed in
the morning me who leaves ammonia lying
around Scott find out the scores oh I
absolutely love that but I have a
question both can't cook so what happens
oh well let's just say our take out the
deliveries are quite something to say
you just go there and he said they have
bad morning breath well that's I refused
to kiss her in the morning so I think
that says enough you guys are still
about how off camera but we want to tell
everybody what the scores were hmm it's
time for that reveal I'm afraid to say
you you your phone's going up I don't
feel good you did not defeat your
partner over there Scott I did not know
and I'm chilly he's gonna just be
talking about this for weeks to come
because he is at the top of our
leaderboard
[Applause]
about the same numbers but in different
order yeah I'm 13 your ideal is that so
you're not for physics we're just gonna
keep scrolling see if you're on that
leaderboards are we let's go again there
you were I'm not gonna get anything and
then you got 13 I'm happy I got more
than one she did she got let's go is
pretty pleased because he's not mark
Hatcher got practice time I didn't get
any practice or anything another guy
host the show thank you very much taking
part of that I loved it so if you guys
ever wanted to expand your knowledge of
World of Warcraft experts over here then
we have just the thing for you markings
go they took to the touchscreen earlier
today to give us an insight into mythic
raiding check this out yes indeed ladies
and gentlemen is time before the break
down and this week I have a World of
Warcraft expert legend I don't know what
else to call you but is of course go
from method and we're gonna be talking
all things World of Warcraft and we're
gonna be starting off talking about
Radian so what is rating rating is
pretty much the toughest challenge in
World of Warcraft it requires a lot of
strategizing a lot of team coordination
and as you can see here at splitting
three difficulty starring at normal then
down to heroic and dime to mythic mythic
is the hardest difficulty and that's
difficulty that the best teams in the
world compete against each other for the
glory okay well let's talk about a
little bit more education here let's
talk about the most recent raid that was
obviously available nine bosses and
let's talk about how many people you can
have involved in this yeah so on normal
and work difficult you can actually
arrange the raid size between ten and
twenty five man raids that lets you know
a lot of people get together and just
play together doesn't actually require a
specific group size on mythic difficulty
the highest difficulty you need 20
players to compete
okay and part three of our little tour
of World of Warcraft rating let's talk
about the composition of the raids
because there's three different
characters that you can have available
to play yeah so if you look at the
mythic difficulty again you've roughly
about two tanks who are those guys are
kind of like you know standing from the
boss absolving what's the damage you
know
face then you have the healers were
playing like the support can enroll
there's about five of those in the
Toyman raid and then of course you have
the VPS which is the damage dealers and
that's kind of split between
Meli damage dealers and ranged damage
dealers and these are the guys who are
they're just damaged you know bring the
damage take the boss down while avoiding
all the raid mechanics it's now one good
question what do you play so I think I
know what you play looking at you I play
attack what a surprise no surprise there
whatsoever now let's talk about the
battle itself because it's not just a
case of fighting a simple boss is it
there's multiple phases to these battles
yeah so this is phase one you're seeing
here this is actually the last fight in
the most recent raid about love dazzle
are you fighting against lady Jaina
Proudmoore
this is the first phase where you're on
the boat and this is actually a boss
that was very difficult it took us over
300 pools to kill this boss it's about
six days six days worth of effort we're
talking long days as well 12 to 14 hours
of playing and so you can see us doing
phase one here on the ship or you know
dealing with various different mechanics
and the fight progresses into into an
intermission phase then phase two then
another intermission phase then the
final phase three so this fight itself
you know takes over ten minutes roughly
and you can see us going into the second
mission phase here however obviously
before that there was a previous
intermission which basically involved
Jaina jumping off the ship into the
middle of the ocean freezing the ocean
and then you basically have to catch up
with her do we like a blizzard for your
very limited visibility and carry the
fight on there then one question I had
for you is obviously you talking about
the final part of the battle as well
because you said how many hours go into
this how much preparation goes into this
we're talking about the final part of
the battle here
how does it feel at the end when you
know you're getting so close what sort
of men so even to get this stage of the
fire requires a lot of focus a lot of
determination and obviously some great
play great strategy because this is what
we're looking at here is the last phase
of the fight you can see jános health is
actually extremely low under on the
screen here and so we're about to go for
the kill and so at this point you know
the world first was still up for grabs
and we knew that the other teams what I
love most about it this is why I asking
the questions because so much time
effort sweat blood tears goes into it
and we just saw the reaction I mean how
does it feel to finally get it done
oh I mean if you saw my point of view
down there I literally jump off the
floor so it was definitely a very
exciting time because I mean I don't
really jump that often so it was a lot
of adrenaline a lot of celebration we
were all playing from roughly the same
place as well so we actually managed to
celebrate as a group and it was
yeah it was good okay amazing well thank
you so much for giving us a little
insight into raiding and of course World
of Warcraft but that's not of course all
we have today on the show we've got
plenty more to show you so let's have a
look at what's coming up coming up next
we learn the story of split gate we'll
be speaking to streaming sensation
scissors and there's plenty to look
forward to in the month ahead
[Music]
lots still to come ads you can see but
one game that we want to talk about a
little bit is the game that is taking
the office by storm and that is of
course split gate now if you like halo
you like portals you might do you play a
lot Hillary one okay well this might be
the game for you we were lucky enough to
catch up with the developers of split
gate to see how the game came together
so split gates well a lot of people
would describe it as old-school halo
mixes portal the biggest thing about
split gate is it fundamentally changes
the way that arena shooters are played
[Music]
I'm Ian Peru I'm the CEO and co-founder
of 10:47 games I'm Nicolas became Ian
and I'm the CTO at 10:47 games
10:47 is the address of the dorm that
Nick and I were in we ended up getting
put into this old frat house that turned
into a dorm but they didn't have a name
for it so it was just 10:47 we couldn't
think of a good name we're not very good
at coming up with names but now we're in
our Atherton office in the bay area it's
my parents old office actually at their
house this is kind of where the first
little bit of the company was here
started off as a school project with the
idea of like let's put portals into a
first-person shooter when we were
getting ready to graduate
my co-founder Nick and I were like man
we have a real opportunity here our
games very fun it's very unique and we
love doing what we're doing so let's go
after this it's perfect time is now Nick
he had already accepted a full-time
offer from Amazon I mean he convinced me
to not pursue the job and pursue the
game and then at that point I was in it
for the long run
basically the other day the experience
that I've had working on this game is
nothing I would have got elsewhere the
month leading up to launch was a really
stressful experience
Nick was going to bed at 9 a.m. every
day getting up at like 11:30 I was up
for 62 hours straight he's like I'm
going to sleep right now I'm gonna wake
up and I'm not gonna sleep until launch
I wouldn't recommend anyone go through
that on the 22nd we were supposed to
launch at 9 a.m. at 5 a.m. everybody
finished everything at 6 a.m. we tested
it the first game somebody crashed at
that point we're like all right we can't
ship this this thing is not tested guys
there's gonna be other sloppy errors we
haven't slept for three days and so that
was a very difficult conversation we
thought we're gonna pull this off we
didn't want to let our community down we
basically slept that whole day for like
eight hours and then got up at 8 p.m.
and then just pulled another two
all-nighters in a row but then we pulled
it off
when launch day came
we hit that button to me it was sort of
a relief that month of hard work kinda
came to a close the coolest thing was
seeing the competitive players ogre -
for example I've been a fan of him for
ever since the Halo 2 days seeing the
fact that this legend that I grew up
watching playing Halo is playing my game
he's loving it and he's playing the next
day and the day after that that was just
so excited to see to have such a
personal product out is both stressful
and rewarding sometimes I kind of sit
back and I'm like wow like I really made
this this has been about making the game
that I love that a lot of people don't
have there's nothing out there that
brings you back to your childhood right
now at least for me and I'm really
thought that this is what it would be it
is really rewarding and it's been an
amazing experience and I'm really
excited to see the future of it well
Marc you're watching that video there
quite closely
that was your thoughts on that you look
pretty excited about it I mean I love
you know arena shooters FPS is my jam
that's what I do so yeah can't wait to
play some more split gate it looks like
a lot of fun okay - loves it I
absolutely love the whole thing those
like that how they were up they said for
three days then they had a full day of
sleep which apparently is eight hours no
one sleeps in this world anyway someone
I hope is sleeping because she is
carrying a little baby on board over
here is our next guest who's ours how
are you doing good really good thing
well I'm really excited to hear about
your journey and to share it everyone
else but for those of you who don't know
much about scissors here's a little
glimpse into what she gets up to
[Music]
he got trapped in his own trap all that
is excellent where do we put the
container down so I'm just gonna pick up
with like the fact that we were all
laughing but then ask you how long it
took to make that food and then how long
it took to just I having food ruined
even you know it was it took about ten
minutes and obviously you have to like
that game's ridiculous that you have to
cut everything precisely into quarters
and then to drop it on the floor just
yeah right now just leave it's just tell
us about your journey and how you came
to join us on the sofa so I started in
around 2014 I actually started playing
Wow and I remember I started streaming
because I was playing Wow and I didn't
have any friends basically I know I want
to play with and my partner was like
joint which because you can meet people
like similar-minded and then it just
escalated and now it's like five years
later and I'm still here so I must be
doing something right or wrong you guys
you know of Joey a little bit before she
was kind of a method as well didn't you
yeah I remember watching her like five
years ago like playing karaoke find it
which only stays for like 60 days what
were you singing oh gosh I can't
anything everything in any of I just
remember thinking all this is a really
fun stream like I can't want to be like
that one day yeah yeah
you kind of just get involved in it in
the first way what made you want to
start streaming I mean I was just doing
it because I've got my first stream on
YouTube and it's shocking that no it is
it's like I'm just like yeah I'm like a
deer lost in headlocks but like it was
literally I just did it because I was
playing and I was like oh I'll meet
people like I said and then it just yeah
it just took off and I met some amazing
people like from it and like been given
so many great opportunities it's a
really really great platform that's
amazing I mean I wanted to kind of pick
your brains a little bit cuz you got
yourself into position now where you
have a really solid community behind you
who watches when you stream what advice
would you be giving to somebody's
streamers and this is nearly not only to
yourself but maybe open up because I
know pretty much everyone on this couch
as streams when they're playing video
games I mean what would you what would
your advice be so to me like obviously
you've got to have fun doing it if
you're not having fun then why are you
doing it in the first place but it's it
sounds weird but you have to be like you
have to think as a viewer like why am i
watching this stream what are you giving
that makes the viewers want to watch it
whether it's like real amazing gameplay
or you've got an amazing personality and
you're obviously bringing something to
the table like people aren't going to
watch someone that isn't having fun and
it's just sitting there just playing a
game because they can do that themselves
I don't know how I get viewers ylim
[Laughter]
advice anyone gave you as well along the
way that you've really taken to heart
and that's kind of what got you into it
or has made you where you are now
I don't know about any in particular
piece of advice but I do think that it's
really important to collaborate with
other streamers I mean this is a
community platform right that everybody
is doing the same thing why not you know
play games with other streamers or
collaborate with them and whatever you
do on your stream and that way everybody
can grow together I want to see that
collaboration happen anyway we're going
to talk to you about that and how that
came about and when it did because it's
quite new isn't it yeah I'm gonna
approach you back in January and like
I've never had
like her proper sponsorship like this
was the biggest opportunity I've been
given throughout my twitch career and
they were like yeah we're gonna fly you
out to Vienna and you're going to a
photo shoot I'm like me have you seen
and then obviously a couple of days
afterwards I found out I was pregnant
and I was like oh my goodness like but
they've been really good about it and I
like met some amazing people and got to
stream because we do crossover streams
where basically it's another member of
the omen squad teaching me how to play a
game and I remember it was two hours
like last week of me and cyanide playing
pop G and I didn't even get a kill when
we won our first game but then 100 set
records I died to the like the last guy
remaining and gave him the opportunity
to you know so I and how do you see this
collaboration going forward what you
know do you hope to where do you hope to
go from here I mean I love streaming I
always have done and in my head I just
wanted I'm so grateful for like every
single day that I get to do this
full-time like I just just want to like
keep it going as long as I can and if
people still want to watch me then hey
this is like let them I'll let them PB
food says SARS there's a lot of s's and
a lot of Zed's in it but you'll find it
just maybe if you even even if you type
it on Twitter the gifts I've got like a
gift section or just me as a crab so you
want to thank you very much for asking
some questions from our set but you know
there's been some some other stuff
that's been going on at the moment I've
been doing stuff Rachel you haven't
asked me about what I've been doing what
have you been doing well thank you for
asking
it's fun of you ask ya face it return to
the UK this month with ECS London 2019
and I had the chance to head some when
Belly arena and meet up with eSports
photographer year and only that
all-round amazing human being Joe Brady
to give us an insight onto how he shoots
the events
[Music]
three-two-one
could see
[Music]
[Music]
as his guide as a music photographer so
I used to troll around the world with
Manchester and then I'm a huge gamer as
well so I started shooting that gave me
events and they just kind of like
one thing led to another yeah I've been
doing eSports now like just eSports for
like three and a half years I think
[Music]
I personally love shooting CS because
you know being able to support the scene
and see see the crowd loving it and
getting involved and yes just it's just
awesome and I love giving back with what
I can do to the counter-strike community
I think my favorite aspect of shooting
eSports is just being able to tell the
stories of the events just being able to
capture that that raw emotion and the
passion I love capturing those moments
that the one-off situation is that you
can't really recreate it capturing that
for their for their memories you know
when they're older they might have that
picture on the wall and build a hey son
look that's when I was a counter-strike
champion and just being being able to be
involved in that is special I think
there's one photo I took Katowice in
2016 of Olaf Meister and it was the
moment that they won the whole
tournament in Poland and everything just
came together in that photo for me it
was quite a special photo and fnatic
actually went on to print that photo on
a mouse man they've got it printed like
huge up in their headquarters I think
that's personally my favorite though so
I've taken
[Applause]
because it's the one-shot wonder like if
you miss it that's it so yeah this is
where all the pressure is I think but
I'm not mess what up yet so Diggs
Leachman stand we need to clean what is
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Counter Strike is personally my favorite
game and being able to shoot in my home
country just incredibly special it all
kind of began as an accident to be
honest so it's just kind of one thing as
led to another right place right time
and never look back to release amazing
stuff there from Joe Brady amazing stuff
yes 2019 as well huge thanks to face it
for inviting us along and you can see
what a talented man he is yes I did I
love you Joe without getting that stress
even though he did say it's quite
stressful at some times but like how he
captures those moments for the players
as well like it's it's an art form he's
amazing it is right but next up it's
time to speak to another guest
everything about works its dumpy and
some piously we've introduced every
other guest with a video doodling stumpy
I went on Twitter and I came across his
Twitter page and his Twitter headline
picture kind of stopped me in my tracks
so I thought I'd show it to you guys
it's him in a bad way I feel like I
should explain myself I feel like you
really should so I thought it was mono
my girlfriend first holiday away it was
a lovely thing really really nice place
some reason there was a bath in our
bedroom don't know why Just Breathe full
bath my bedroom I thought there's
nothing more romantic than her taking a
picture of me looking at me like oh you
caught me don't quit as we all there I
thought let's display them for the world
to see I still love that there's nothing
more I'll stick by is it quite a
conversation starter as well it seems
like it is yeah my dad sent me what's
that message saying did you mean to do
oh absolutely love it but let's just
chat about your crew of how about
everyone else's you know you play
yourself and now you're a caster like
talk us through your journey so started
everything with rocket League so came
out in 2015
went to a friend's house to play that I
had on PS Plus became as free on that in
its first week I thought that alright
went back home have a console one of my
friends actually bought me rocket League
so I would then play with him and I
thought okay I'll give it a go play
together I was playing we weren't
together healing stops on route saw like
five six hours I've got just over three
and a half thousand hours in that game
now and it basically got to a point
where I was watching streams and my
stream with coal wars have a TV show
with coal and half business and I was
watching him stream and he said I was
funnier than him in twitch chat even
with 15 seconds of delay you know I'll
take that so yes we said John half on
business
go on then that's the worst offer it
could have made he should've gone 70/30
and then the first real thing that I
ever did in eSports was here in gfinity
elite series cast in the rocket League
an amazing brakes myself is such a big
platform I secured or doing it and that
was my first stepping-stone on a pretty
decent career sort of in eSports so
you've heard a little bit of a look
change movie series well last time we
were together obviously we can't say we
tell us about the chop because that must
have been a big thing for ya when I was
at uni I basically got long hair because
haircuts were expensive it was like
about 30 quid for a haircut yeah I was
like you know what I'm not doing that
seeing as where I was about my local
village it was five pounds for a haircut
so instead of going home and getting us
look you know anymore it got down to
path my collarbone chopped off this is
two weeks ago how much
I went my girlfriend booked me in for a
haircut and I went I got it all chopped
off and then he minded that he never
grew back any problem yo girl
yeah when much shorter he is down to
past my collarbone about two weeks ago
and there ish it's got noises it was
getting hot I think no I just give it a
shot but I said to her half way down the
neck how's that yes sounds good
I just how difficult was it to
transition into being a caster was it
nerve-racking
the first week of the chief initally
series is still one of my most
nerve-wracking things I've ever done on
see it was the same as having that
haircut I'm not even kidding the same as
me sitting in that check I don't have
like two years but coming into here I'll
feel amazing studio there's cameras
everywhere I hadn't really done it
before
it was terrifying about every single
time that I'm asked to an event I'm like
yes let's do it and I'm always so
excited to get involved no one wants to
ask you about something that happened
very recently as well last weekend we
had the our LCS vitality taking home the
win come on Europe we did we are great
you're rocking late as simple as that
but what your thoughts than that and
also the future of Rockley eSports
vitality day are hands down the best
team they were at the moment they beat
cloud nine quite handily they did really
really well there they beat them for oh
and the best-of-seven series didn't drop
a game against them in the quarterfinals
they managed to beat the probably
favourites one of the favored stiff
tournament three one then in the finals
they weren't for one against GT well
gigantic squad yeah and they just
systematically broke them down and they
could hardly get on there it was and in
literally 15 seconds for some people who
aren't rocket League pads explain who
scrub killer is because they started
playing when he was like 12 is now one
of the best players in the world and
played the prequel supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered battle cars when he was
six years old I love supersonic
acrobatics Crockett is just phenomenal
and he's just won herself 200 grand and
he's like
and he's from Scotland anyway yeah
that's good it'll for now for stumpy
thank you so much for I have a little
chat with us here we've got plenty more
to come though let's have a little look
and a reminder of exactly what's coming
up still to come on today's show we'll
be back for round two of the rocket
League challenge
and finally we're seeing what's to come
in the month ahead okay
well I'm pretty excited but what is
coming up next because it is time for
the hotly contested rocket League
challenge now and time to see which of
you at home made the right cool
- grab themselves some omen by HP
goodies okay I'm gonna see if I was able
to keep lotteries and winning streak up
from episode 1 smile so we're back here
we are again for the rocket League
challenge and I've got myself a new
teammate this time Richard seems you
were terrible last time so I'm 14
scissors how are we feeling about this
because as you might know unfortunately
team like took over the windows mm-hmm
I mean I think you've been stitched up
again because I've got zero rocket Lea
oh okay well I mean speaking of ours we
should probably introduce the other team
Rachel welcome along obviously your
first time here at the rocket League
challenge representing Team Lottie and
mr. three and a half thousand hours
himself oh hello mate it's good to be
back and this is the stitch up of home
stitch I don't know what you mean I mean
this is gonna be a pretty even match I
hope I think roads have fun in the days
don't think no no some people hate to
win artwork oh sorry wrong script we're
here to win we're gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you were going straight for a new risk
oh yeah positivity oh my what all right
oh babe what does he do a thousand hours
I remember we all have items okay we use
our special item ready that was
everything the goal the goal if you guys
get half the guns we score you will know
okay
he's got five ice cold one
no the guys how does it feel being
Brazil in this Germany Brazil five score
game how does that feel I'm just saying
the Brazil didn't win that World Cup and
boy did you used to be a rocket League
caster yeah but we all know the rules if
you can't play you coach and if you
can't coach your cast so that's that's
the rule is the next game run next week
Elite exploded Oh does she hit it
let's go don't be just like there we are
g-g-gee fancy a rematch goes or I fancy
the fact that we've got a lot more to
talk about
I'm the rest of the show congratulations
applause team lie to Rachel and to
stumpy commiseration it was always gonna
happen wasn't it let's face it when I
seem to have yeah
no luck when it comes to rocking a
challenge but unfortunately I'm now two
and zero down so graduations guys but
grudgingly well done in a half thousand
hours how are they ever gonna lose ah
first we just do this film again just
one that was almost like Lauren Gerrie
headshot John yeah fine cuz also Timothy
I think they're two Nilla yeah that I
can't wait to play with someone with
three and a half thousand hours both of
us would have won if we had some people
on Team hang on hang on how many girls
did you score one I scored two on my own
you did so even it was just you and I
heads head I would still be in it
there's so much to look forward to let's
just leave that for a moment there is so
much to look forward to in the coming
weeks almost too much to get our heads
around luckily for you guys at home
we've put together a little guide as to
what to note down in your diary
epicenter Moscow the last dota major of
the year comes to a close
[Music]
CEO 2019 one of the fighting game
community's most unique events returns
to Daytona Beach
what does it mean to you what does it
mean to all of the nura Rango players
[Music]
ESL one cologne for the fifth year csgo
returns to Germany o WL stage 3 playoffs
the overwatch league second season
continues with its second home game in
Atlanta
WCS summer 2019 the Starcraft 2 scene
celebrates its second major of the year
[Music]
okay right well we've still got these
guests for a couple of minutes so I just
want to see what you guys have got
coming up next go I know you mentioned
that method I've got some exciting
things on the horizon as always so I
mean if anyone likes water work
afternoon like epic events there is the
next based world first coming up on July
the 16th it's when we kick off that's
not about three weeks from now so it
makes you tune in to the method channel
for that that's gonna be a big thing
guys what else that nails got on their
agenda obviously a baby way yeah like
delivering babies and dropping more food
probably for me 23rd of September
reading my birthday's 24th so stumpy big
rocket League events coming up in
Dreamhack we have one in Valencia in
mid-july and then we've also got
Montreal
towards the end of year 1 2000 dollars
like rocket League definitely chew into
them Joey you want to come back so miss
kind of miscue quickie you know I've got
things coming over there not necessarily
sports related how is nice yeah yeah
yeah yeah one of them
no no you know karaokes not not one of
my strong suits but yeah I mean a makeup
competition at the moment in the UK
cause the NYX face awards and yeah
hopefully fingers crossed multi-talented
people well good luck with everything
you have going on but right now it's
time to hand over to mark with our
competition winner thank you very much
very excited of course and thank you to
everyone who is of course entered into
the competition for today but I have the
great power to reveal who has won our
competition and it is the wit the white
right I can't read the white row
congratulations to you on winning the
competition we in touch with it
everything that we need to do to get you
your prizes fantastic stuff but before
we close things out I just have a little
bit of a question that's come in from
Twitter as well for some of the guys on
the couch which is coming in for a real
dire core and he says what do you think
that the deal with Epic Games owning
psionics now
to do with the games and the community
full details please and it's very
specific full details please so full
details please ladies and gentlemen on
the couch what your thoughts on this one
well I guess that is a question really
for stumpy over there if you could read
it if not I'll just go for it what do
you think a deal with Epic Games owning
psionic now due to the games and that
community I personally and if people
don't like epic at the moment there's a
few Sodor things going on people aren't
a fan of what they did with the store I
think I think it's fantastic I really
like it I'm excited to see what they can
do there's a lot of money obvious with
epic come from the four light side of
things so if there's stuff from that and
sort of the marketing they've got from
Fortner what they've learned there if
that can we move towards rocket League
as well it's a very family-friendly game
it's saying that could be marketed a lot
better the price books could get larger
the events could just be even nicer so I
think I think it's all totally going to
be a very very good thing for rocket
League thank you so much for answering
that question and thank you for joining
us thank you so all we have time for
tonight I feel like time is just flying
by today hasn't it Rachel you've
absolutely killed it great to have you
along all again thank you all for
watching good night
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you